sometimes watching a movie isn't enough
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipes today we're
with chef Jennifer Carroll at kapnos in
Washington DC we have challenged her
with creating a dish fit for lady
monologue chef Carol has prepared a list
of essential ingredients to do just that
they are citrus or the marmol on blood
orange see the resemblance and duck
confit
it's French bitch Bon Appetit
[Music]
ruch uh hell is this gonna be I have
absolutely no clue but if it's anything
like the movie it'll be like a super
lavish and crazy dish
it better be delivered to me in song
yeah I don't want to see someone come
around the corner rocks yeah yeah we get
a Roxanne dish then I don't I really
don't want to have any part of that at
all
[Music]
so Moulin Rouge for me is a movie it's
really two movies it's a tale of two
halves first half I'm in like it's wacky
it's crazy
it's busy it's all over the place but
I'm I'm in and then we get to the second
half where it turns like super sad and
romantic and tragic yeah and I start to
fade away yeah
Satine has this disease that is going to
end in the blood coughing Zhi the blood
coughing disease hopefully we won't have
a dish related to that either
[Music]
what is the when we did this bit this
movie for the sins video I remember
something about the villain what do we
know him from
besides this movie Richard Roxburgh he
is the guy who played the villain and
what's he you well we have we have the
Internet go ahead and do it the first
time we've you can fix it as host right
fix it in post now they're gonna zoom in
on I try and laugh at you yeah laughter
see y'all lady mom I know there's
something with this guy oh yeah you know
he was in some other van helsing it
might have been van helsing it's not bad
he'll sing along roof Mission Possible -
Oh screw it yeah totally this one
what was your favorite song that they
did in there oh the the really busy
opening one gaga oh yeah the can-can
yeah
just because it's it just overwhelms you
with sensory you know sights and sounds
I do love I love how they introduce it
to Jim Broadbent he's great in the movie
in broad bed he's like he's like he's
just whispers it like and then and then
I got a guy guys got you can can can
then it goes nuts yeah
[Music]
hi guys so I have your rule are huge oh
wow
so it's a crispy duck confit with black
garlic and orange marmalade a little bit
of cauliflower and white and sparing a
salad it looks amazing
thank you it looks every bit as busy as
a Moulin Rouge yes the crazy costumes
and colors and extravaganza hopefully
the flavor explosion oh yeah it looks
like a shame actually you know cut into
this it's like a work of art this is
only my second time in my life having
done really missing out I am missing out
that's delicious from the sweetness yeah
really complements the I don't know how
to say it in foodie terms but it's good
it's good it's good
so you have navel oranges and blood
oranges on there and that is part of the
mom a lot if you have candied kumquats
in there you have fresh orange and blood
orange you have a orange juice reduction
with a little bit of sugar cardamom all
mixed into everything you have the blood
orange piste puree on there as well so
your multiple components of orange and
marmalade no it's uh it's just
I'm just an explosion of flavors really
great the sauce underneath on the plate
that you're seeing right here that's the
black garlic sauce and so there's a
little bit of heat in there there's Thai
chili peppers and I love it I think it's
such a great complement to the orange
and to the duck itself
are you a big fan of the movie I am I
haven't seen it in a long time but I
remember when it came out that just like
the elaborate yes show eNOS it's really
related to me and what I do now so it's
just a really fun movie this would fit
perfectly in the movie for sure oh yeah
oh yeah and we were it's funny that we
were talking earlier about both the
extravagance and the earnestness of the
movie and it's sort of a balance of both
right it's like way over the top in some
ways but in in the songs it's like as
honest and earnest as any movie can be
right I like that
we picked up the same thing you did I
want to stop eating stuff I know we
don't have to I got more in the kitchen
it's definitely the best meal I've ever
had in my life before noon yeah that is
true this is pretty early
thanks to Jennifer for the fantastic
taste of France make sure you head over
to the community table channel to hear
more from her and all the other chefs we
got to hang out with thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time on movie
recipes
[Music]